We're here with the intrepid journalist
and amazing human, Lisa Ling!
(audience claps and cheers)
Lisa's show, This Is Life,
kicks off its eighth season,
which, I mean, sounds like a lot,
but you have been doing this
far before even this show
and let's take a look at a clip
from the premiere show.
By 1982, one in five Detroit residents
were out of job.
People want to know why is this happening to me?
Who can I blame?
In the beginning, the workers blamed the companies.
Factories blame the workers.
The politicians blamed each other.
And in the end they kind of all reached a consensus.
Let's blame Japan.
Okay.
So that clip sets up the scene to talk about the story of
Vincent Chin.
And I was wondering if you could share that with us?
Yeah. So this season of This Is Life,
we're doing something a little different because of COVID.
We decided to pivot and ground each episode of the season in
a moment in American history that didn't make it into the
history books and to kind of dissect it,
to figure out how it has impacted where we are today.
And Vincent Chin was a young Chinese American man
who lived in Detroit,
and Detroit during the eighties was the automobile capital
of the world.
And at a certain point there was this economic downturn and
people were losing jobs left and right,
and as Helen Zia, the journalist said,
people started blaming Japanese car manufacturers
because they were producing much more fuel
efficient cars.
So, Vincent Chin was at a bar in Detroit
and having a good time celebrating his bachelor party.
And two out of work auto workers accused him
of being a Japanese
and they got into an altercation.
The two men got kicked out,
they waited for Vincent Chin.
And so after Vincent Chin's, uh, murder,
the killers never served a day in jail or prison.
They got served a $3,000 fine.
They even pled guilty.
And it, it was one of those moments
in Asian-American history that
the community became really galvanized.
That case became the first civil rights case involving an
Asian-American in American history.
And when you look at what's happening today over the past
year and a half, since COVID became rooted in this country,
so many Asians have been targeted because the origins of
COVID were China, for no reason.
And we, we look at this story because in some ways
it's not different from what happened during the 1980s.
And there's just this been this pattern of discrimination
and scapegoating of Asian-Americans for,
th-, th-, that has spanned more than a century.
So, I think it's really important
that we go back and look
into those moments that didn't make it
into the history books,
because we can't know how to fix things.
We can't really know where we're going,
unless we know where we've been.
I love that.
And, you know,
we learned so much when, when you put these, this,
these historical moments into context for us,
what do you want the viewer to take away from this?
Well, I think it's really interesting that right now,
one of the fiercest debates going on in the government and
in local legislatures in school,
on school boards is over what to teach our kids.
Like what kind of history to teach.
And I, I think that it's really important
to, to equip our kids with a whole array of history
because history in America has been told through
a certain lens.
I mean, my own kids are only eight and five,
but I've told them about the internment of
Japanese Americans.
I've told them about the Chinese Exclusion Act.
They know who Rosa Parks was.
They know what Jim Crow laws were.
And, you know, I've been teaching them
to stand up for themselves
and stand up for other people.
And a couple of months ago,
a little boy at my daughter's school called her Ching Chong.
And without missing a beat, her best friend said,
"I will not be a bystander!"
And,
Wow!
[audience claps and Cheers]
And went and told the teacher.
And like to me, that was an example of,
of really great parenting, educating our kids,
making them aware of,
of the importance of standing up for all people,
irrespective of their, their gender,
their, their race, et cetera.
And I think we need to,
we need to get back together
I agree.
and understanding each other.
[audience claps]
( Drew) I agree completely.
Well thank you.
And the Asian American Foundation
is something that you've worked really closely on.
Right?
Yeah.
Well, I would love, uh, to make a donation.
We admire everything that you do.
And we reached out to One Hope Wine
and Napa Valley Winery
on a mission to nourish the future.
And I thank them so much because they're going to donate
$10,000.
[audience claps and cheers loudly]
to the Asian American Foundation.
And I know I love you, Lisa Ling,
so much
Thank you.
Thank you so much for gracing
this news desk with your amazing intrepid presence.
Well, and all stories that you'll see, I mean,
these are stories about, you know, our history.
It's not just Asian-American history in this first episode.
It's all of our history.
( Drew) Yes, absolutely.
Thank you.
Well, Lisa's show,
This Is Life with Lisa Ling
returns this Sunday,
and will be available to stream on CNN Go as well.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)